we have some disturbing end of the year  news brought to you by a florida man is  2021's version of harambe who was of  course the guerrilla shot in the  cincinnati uh zoo in 2016 after a boy  climbed into its enclosure  an endangered malayan tiger named echo  from the naples zoo in florida is now  dead after a man decided to put his arm  inside the tiger's cage  according to the local sheriff a 26 year  old who worked for a cleaning service  was trying to pet the tiger police say  they shot the tiger because they  couldn't find a tranquilizer like  harambee before him we remember ekko the  tiger  rest in peace hey sean hannity here hey  click here to subscribe to fox news  youtube page and catch our hottest  interviews and most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else